hi there
steve here i don't know how this is all
gonna work out i'm using a little
microphone here
i don't know if the lighting is too
bright here but i have my christmas tree
behind me
uh and it's the day after christmas
and um
yeah you know i was on uh
facebook and uh ollie richards who's a
great polyglot had posted a picture of
himself uh reading a trilingual book and
said he was doing like steve kaufman
reading in different languages and
listening and stuff so i commented there
that
i don't like bilingual let alone
trilingual books i find it distracting i
like to stay in the language
occasionally go out to find a word that
i need but
stay in the language but other people
love bilingual books they're very
popular so it just goes to show you
there's all kinds of different ways of
learning languages and on that someone
asked either me or ollie i'm not sure
who the question was directed at
do you ever take a break from language
learning well
you know
never take a break from doing things
that you like to do do you ever take a
break from reading uh to me it's just uh
enjoyable i like reading about the
history now and listening to the history
of ukraine and poland and czech republic
and
and russia and so forth and so on but
today i was about to settle down after a
late breakfast with my wife we've had
two nights of christmas meals christmas
eve christmas dinner
having a leisurely breakfast eating our
christmas cookies with coffee
and my son phoned up and said that we've
got to go snowshoeing so
i didn't do any language learning i went
up snowshoeing and i will add here a
couple of short videos from our
snowshoeing
and i will have a link
in the description box to a video about
snowshoeing up at cypress bowl cypress
bowl is about 20 minutes by car from
where we are we're right down by the
water and it can be raining down here
it'll be snowing up there they have
three and a half meters of snow and it's
lovely so uh and uh please continue
enjoying your holidays
bye for now
go with mark
go
yeah
yeah
okay
all right
okay all right so i was sitting at home
boxing day 26th of december
and i was gonna settle into listening
and reading to my ukrainian and polish
in czech and russian history and my son
mark phones and he says we're going
snowshoeing
so here i am
just 20 minutes from my home it's
snowing like mad there's got to be five
meters of snow on the ground it's a
wonderful snowy wilderness merry
christmas happy new year
say hi gord
merry christmas